okay so we're gonna mic you that's me
Jesse I'm single like really single
so can you I guess take off your shirt
that a real request I'm really exhausted
from dating accept it Mike you okay I
thought since I live in LA
naturally the easiest thing to do would
be hold a casting calls so just say that
you love Jewish girls into the mic I
just love Jewish girls they had no idea
they were auditioning to be my real
boyfriend so thank you so much for
coming in today I have a couple
questions for you what's your sign
Capricorn what's your biggest fear
sharks eating me or may mean what's your
relationship like with your mom oh great
do you have a history of male pattern
baldness in your field yes who's your
dream girl dream girl hmm oh I mean a
girl for one definitely Kim Kardashian
brunette probably maybe blonde Natalie
Portman Belle from Beauty and the Beast
when she falls off the horse and that
little strand of hair comes down Natalie
Portman what is the deal with Natalie
friggin Portman she's beautiful
too hard word honestly I'm not John I
didn't say you were but like what is cuz
I'm Jewish too you know what it means
you're almost too Jewish
she's like slightly Jewish she's like
got like a sprinkle of Jew okay you've
got a little you're kind of full frontal
too I'm not saying that's bad
turn off mr. newm I like Jews okay okay
since it was an audition
I picked a scene from maybe the most
romantic movie of all time The Notebook
why did he write me why it wasn't over
for me
I win resetting years but now it's too
late
I wrote you 365 letters I wrote you
every day for a year who me yes it
wasn't it wasn't over it still isn't
over this is a Gosling movie
kisses Ally kisses
ally no girl like that is that not a
thing for the final section I fed them
some lines before me
so I'm just gonna say these lines then
you repeat them back to me okay
everything you say is really relevant I
really say is really relevant please
tell me all about your feelings and how
you feel about your feelings trying to
go hold hands outside in the rain in
front of your ex-boyfriends house your
feminist rhetoric really turns me on
is it hard being so much prettier than
your friends
yeah no I never no sorry not on that oh
yeah it is really hard though I hate
[ __ ] well it's not true but I tried
to put myself in the position of someone
who does so then it came time to make a
decision and the decision was pretty
easy
after a lot of deliberation you did not
get the part where did I go wrong
so money please you look really upset
are you crying yeah great so I can go
right I can leave and not see you you
should probably wait congratulations you
got the part
good great thank you do you want to get
married I'm getting married in August oh
that's totally great are you sorry
you're like really getting married yeah
well that didn't work
can you demo your special skills
your feminist rhetoric really turns me
on